I don't care what anybody says,
if you hear a man saying that he hates Taylor Swift,
what he's really saying is that he hates all women.
Okay, great.
Now that I've got everyone's attention.
Um, thank you so much.
Look at this. We are almost there.
Only 8,000, less than 8,000 euros to go.
A couple days ago, this was at 15.
So, thank you so much for donating to this.
It is amazing. 1,386 people have donated.
Abdul and his family are living in ruins.
They simply don't have a choice.
Their home was bombed. It's really hard to provide food for your family
when a bag of flour costs $1,000.
Imagine going down to the supermarket
and having to spend $1,000 on a bag of flour.
So, coordinating an exit cost 5,000.
So, with this money,
we're going to be able to evacuate three families,
15 people. When you donate,
you go and click on the link
and you can literally donate with Apple Pay.
So, it is literally just a click of the button.
It does not take any time.
It literally takes under 30 seconds.
And I just, I don't understand why the billionaires on doing it,
but they're not. So,
if you do have any money, please do that.
If you can share it, please share it. Please. Thank you.